.
unune endémie, et le combat cone
lala COVID-19 devrait-il, à c ce
ststade-ci, davantage ressembler
auau combat contre la grippe?
PlPlusieurs experts se prononcet
dede plus en plus ouvertement
susur ces questions, notamment
lele Dr Karl Weiss,
mimicrobiologiste et infectioloe
etet spécialiste des maladies
ininfectieuses à l l'Hôpipital l
jujuif de Montréal, qu'on joint
àà l l'instant.
B Bonjour, Dr Weiss.
- - Bonjour.
- - On va trancher la question
totout de suite si on est capabe
dede le faire : pandémie, endém,
ouoù en sommes-nous?
- - Ce que je dis, c'est qu'on t
enen train de passer d'une phase
dede pandémie à u une phase end.
CÇa ne se fera pas du jour au
lelendemain. C'est une phase,
c'c'est une transition. C'est ue
esespècece de rivièrere qui arre
dadans l'océan, et l'eau douce e
mémélange à l l'eau de mer.
MaMais entre l'eau de la mèreret
l'l'eau douce, il y a un dégrad.
C'C'est un é état où le virus va
pepersister dans notre
enenvironnement pendant une lone
pépériode, possiblement des
anannées. On va devoir vivre av,
apapprendre à v vivre avec ce ql
reressort de cette discussion
ququand j'en discute avec tous s
cocollègugues, ici et partout au
CaCanada, les gens partagent à u
prprès s tout le mêmeme concept.
- - Quand vous dîtetes d'apprenà
vivivre avec le virus, ça veut
didire quoi concrètetement dans
nonotre contexte à n nous?
- - Ce que ça veut dire, ça veut
didire pourquoi on a mis toutes
leles mesures en place? On les a
mimis en place parce qu'on avait
pepeur que le systèmeme hospitar
sosoit trop débordé. Donc il va
fafalloir faire, il va falloir
s's'assurer qu'on met en place s
memesures pour que les gens qui
sosont à r risque d'êtrtre
hohospitalisé, avec l'arrivée de
bebeaucoup de médicaments, de
nonombreux médicaments qui vont
ararriver et surtout avec la
vavaccination, que ces gens-là,,
bibien vaccinés, ces gens à
ririsque, lorsqu'il va attrapere
COCOVID, on aura des façons de s
gagarder à l l'extérieur de
l'l'hôpipital et les traiter les
vivite possible, pour que ne pas
ilils viennent engorger le syste
hohospitalier. Dans ce contexte-
llà, , les autres feront peut-êe
unune COVID comme ils font une
grgrippe ou un rhume, comme dans
lele passé, et dans ce contexte-
llà, , on retournera dans une ve
ququi est relativement normale.
MaMais on ne peut pas continuerà
avavoir le COVID 6.0 avec la mêe
méméthodologie qu'on avait pendt
leles vagues précédentes.
- - Voilà, , les comparaisons
pepeuvent êtrtre hasardeuses ene
unune vague et l'autre. Mais les
momoyens que vous avez évoqués,
ququ'on a à n notre disposition,
popour revenir à l la normale, s
sosont existants : la vaccinatin
dedes gens vulnérables. Certains
personnes se demandent peut-être
: : pourquoi ne pas commencer
mamaintenant?
- - On commence, on donne des
mémédicaments, on administre des
mémédicaments par la bouche. Les
gegens qui sont positifs à l l'D
etet qui ont des facteurs de
ririsque...
- - Ces mesures sanitaires,
popourquoi ne pas l'élever si cs
sosolutions sont à n notre
didisposition?
- - On a commencé la vaccination
trtrop tôt t trop tard.
IlIl faut finir cette vague même
sisi elle est dans cette phase
dedescendante, cette phase
plplateau. J'avais déjà d dit qe
jujusqu'à l la mi-février, la sn
momodifie-t-il, mais que
l'l'éclaircie et le printemps va
cocommencer à a arriver après s,
auautant pour le COVID que le vi
prprêteteur. On a encore pour ls
dedeux prochaines semaines dans
unune période difficile, où il
fafaut mettre des mesures en ple
fafaire descendre le nombre de
cacas, s'assurer qu'il ne remone
papas et éventuellement passer r
d'd'autres choses. Et surtout, u
popoint de vue social,
pspsychologique, s'assurer que a
popopulation suive, parce qu'ily
a a actuellement une réelle
fafatigue, mêmeme au sein des gs
ququi sont doublement vaccinés,t
ququi maintenant, et pour toutes
sosortes de raisons, je les
enencourage à a aller chercher r
trtroisièmeme dose, se pose des
ququestions devant toutes less
cocontradictions qu'ils ont pu
vovoir en termes de
rerecommandations.
- - Vous sentez que l'élastique
ététirée au maximum? Que
l'l'adhésion est plus ténue?
- - Je sens que l'adhésion dimie
chchez les gens vaccinés, qui ot
écécouté les recommandations qun
lele refait depuis le début. Ils
sese disent : j'ai fait tout ce,
etet finalement on me met un
cocouvre-feu, mes enfants ne
pepeuvent pas jouer au hockey, e
nene peux pas les voir de conce.
LeLes gens se demandent : à q qi
çaça a servi? Il ne faut pas
ououblier que sans le vaccin,
ç'ç'aurait été une catastrophe.i
onon avait eu une vague Omicron
sasans vaccin, on le voit avec s
gegens non vaccinés, on aurait u
ququelque chose de beaucoup plus
teterrible. Le vaccin était très
ututile. Les vaccins ça protègee
cocontre les maladies sévèreresa
vovous empêchchera d'aller aux s
inintensifs à l l'hôpipital.
- - Mais Docteur Weiss, vous avz
évévoqué des réticences à
cecertaines mesures qui ont été
adadoptées très s récemment, en
évévoquant que certaines n'avait
papas de base scientifique. Alos
ququelles sont ces mesures selon
vovous n'ont pas lieu d'êtrtre i
dedevraient êtrtre levées plutôe
d'd'autres?
- - Quand on a dit qu'on devait
fafaire porter des masques à d s
jejeunes qui veulent jouer au
hohockey, on peut se demander,
prprendre des adolescents en
plpleine santé, doublement
vavaccinés, qui pratique un spot
dedehors, est-ce qu'on a besoine
leleur faire porter un masque? l
n'n'y a pas vraiment de sciences
dederrièrere cela. Est-ce que le
ririsque zéro existe? Non, jama.
MaMais, on a des adolescents qui
nene peuvent plus faire leur
spsport. Ils ont un risque trèss
miminime de contracter le COVID,
lele transmettre, et de tomber
mamalade. Il y a un risque en
reretournant les enfants à
l'l'école, mais c'est nettement
mimieux d'aller à l l'école pour
eueux.
- - C'est la capacité du réseaue
sasanté d'absorber les patients
ququi doivent êtrtre traités poe
COCOVID-19 dans une perspectivee
lelevée des restrictions
sasanitaires ou de certaines
d'd'entre elles. Est-ce qu'il ya
lilieu de craindre?
- - Regardez, il n'y a pas si
lolongtemps, on dirait que ni
l'l'hospitalisation d'aller mete
lele réseau sous haute tension.e
réréseau a très s bien tenu. On
auaurait pu encore plus monter,t
çaça aurait tenu.
DoDonc, de façon pratique, s'il
fafallait ouvrir plus d'unités,
auaux soins intensifs, on l'aurt
fafait. Mais ce n'est pas l'idé,
paparce que ça a empêchché beaup
d'd'activités médicales. Beaucop
dede chirurgies ont été annulée.
BeBeaucoup de traitements n'ont
papas été administrés. Les gens
onont mêmeme peur d'aller à
l'l'hôpipital. Ce qui est un
prproblèmeme. On doit appeler ds
gegens pour leur demander pourqi
ilils ne sont pas à l leur rend-
vovous. Ils nous disent : on a
pepeur d'aller à l l'hôpipital.
D'D'autres disent qu'ils n'osent
papas nous déranger, c'est poura
ququ'ils ne viennent pas. Ça
cocontinue d'affecter la
popopulation de toutes sortes de
fafaçons. J'ai un collègugue que
didit que des gens viennent
avaveugle parce qu'ils n'ont pas
leles traitements adéquats et ls
chchirurgies pour le glaucome. l
y y a toutes sortes d'impacts qi
nene sont pas mesurés et qui ne
sosont pas facilement mesurable,
c'c'est pour ça qu'on ne peut ps
sese permettre d'avoir un systèe
ununiquement unidirectionnel. Et
lala majorité des gens qui sontà
l'l'hôpipital pour le COVID, net
papas là p pour le COVID. Leur
adadmission est là p pour quelqe
chchose d'autre, et est ensuite
popositif à l l'COVID.
- - Ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'n
dodoit nécessairement baisser la
gagarde. Ça reste sérieux. C'est
unune question d'équilibre
fifinalement ce qu'on doit en